So, do you have your Tanakh open?
B'seder, yes. Okay, go to Genesis
48:15-16.
Read it slowly for us.
I'm even respecting you calling it the
Tanakh, and I should show you respect
cuz you have no respect for my Christian
brothers and sisters. And you respect
Muslims who bash you and your your
people, but that's okay. And again, like
I said, it shows the spirit that as far
as you
get there.
>> Can you Can you still hear me? Yeah, I
can hear you. I'm just waiting for you
to read it slowly.
All right, and then in English, so he
blessed Joseph and said, "The God before
whom I know whom my fathers Abraham and
Isaac walked, the God who has sustained
me as long as I am alive until this day,
may the angel who redeemed me from all
harm bless the youths, and may he be
called by by my name and my name my
father's Abraham
Abraham and Isaac, and may he multiply
abundantly like fish like fish in the
midst in the midst of the land."
>> Okay, now read 16 slowly again cuz I
like I said, you read too fast. You want
people to follow you. So, read 16 slowly
again.
May the angel who redeemed me from all
harm bless the Now, is the verb bless is
the verb bless singular or plural? You
know Hebrew, right? It is a singular.
Okay, who's blessing the grandchildren?
The angel or God?
Well, it says "amalach" so it would be
here. And if you read the text
precisely, it would be the angel. Okay,
but in 15 he mentioned the God before
whom my fathers walked, the God who fed
me all the days of my life. So, who
exactly is blessing them?
It is a I mean, it would be God as well.
However, uh uh
>> you have God and the angel blessing if
the verb is singular? So, God and the
angel are one?
Not necessarily, no. Okay, explain how
then this is a prayer that he's praying
to God, but then he mentions the angel,
and the verb to bless is singular. How
do you get a singular verb when you
mention God and the angel in this prayer
to bless his grandchildren if the
angel's not somehow connected to God?
Please explain to me. He's invoking the
angel. Is that redeemed him? Don't tap
dance around that. Redeemed
>> Mhm.
So, this is a specific angel that has
accompanied Yakov and has saved him from
his calamities, and he's praying to him
to bless his grandchildren, but he prays
to him right after mentioning God before
Abraham and Isaac walked and God who fed
me. So, how Do you Let me Let me put it
this way so you can see how this gets
you in trouble, you so-called Jews who
believe in the oneness of God like the
Muslims do. Do you today would you pray
to the malach to bless your children if
you had any or grandchildren?
No. Say it again.
No. So, then you're not like Jacob. That
means Jacob would condemn you because he
did pray to an angel.
Well, and if you want to understand the
interpretation of this verse, we view
here as it says "amalach hagoyel"
essentially means, you know, either
doing two things to be the angel or the
redeemer. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah, of course. So,
I'll explain now. So, it essentially is,
you know, more you know, of a metaphor,
for example. So, for we can see in a
Genesis, you know, chapter 31:11-13
>> proves my point, not yours. Genesis 31
is the next verse I was going to go to.
It proves my point, not yours. Cuz then
again, that angel who's been
accompanying him and saving him, the
angel says, "I'm the God of Bethel."
Can Do you believe an angel can say "I'm
the God of Bethel," the house of God?
That actually backfired against you.
That was the next verse I was going to
go to.
>> I believe Well, I I was going to explain
this is why I would I was explaining the
Judaism's view of what they what the
angel of the Lord is.
And firstly, I want to say we believe
the reason why he is saying, you know,
the angel is the redeemer, correct, is
because of the fact that he is ascribing
essentially the actions of God on Earth
to the angel, and that's what we all
essentially That is what we believe
generally about many different passages
in our Tanakh that use the word "angel
of the Lord." We believe the same thing
for here as well, that essentially
"hamalach hagoyel," right?
>> Is who? Is "hamalach hagoyel" then? It
is the malach is the malach is referring
to God. However, So, the malach is God.
Good, excellent. Thank you. No, no.
Well, I wasn't finished though. The
malach is essentially not coeternal with
God is my point.
>> Show me where it says he's not
coeternal. Don't tell me what you
believe. Show me what you can prove. I
don't care what Judaism believes. I care
what you can prove from scripture. You
just read so much into the text. Show me
this "hamalach" is not eternal. Show me
where it says he's created.
Well, I didn't necessarily say it was
created, but it also doesn't say that
he's necessarily
>> Yes, it does. When he says he's the God
of Bethel, and Jacob prays to him, and
then God says, "My name is in him." You
don't get any clearer proof that this
angel cannot be a creature if he's the
God of Bethel, and you can pray to him.
And then in Exodus 23, go to Exodus
23:20-21.
I don't care what Judaism says. I care
what Judaism proves. Don't give me your
personal beliefs. Prove it to me from
scripture. And your scripture. I haven't
even used the New Testament. And don't
tell me what you think it means. Deal
with the grammar and the syntax cuz you
say you know Hebrew. So, go to Exodus
23:20-21.
Okay. Read it for me, please, slowly.
Behold, I am sending an angel before you
to guard you on the way and to bring you
to the place I have prepared. Beware of
him and obey him. Do not rebel against
him, for he will not forgive your
transgression, for my name is within
him.
My name is what?
Within him. So, do you believe Do you
believe that God's name can be embodied
by a creature so that he can do what God
does, forgive sins, because he warned
them. Be careful of this angel. He won't
forgive you, and he explains why, "For
my name is in him." So, a creature can
do what God does, forgive sins, because
he embodies the name of God. And more
importantly, what does name mean
according to the Hebrew? When you speak
of the name of God, what are you saying?
Well, you can say, you know, name is in
referring to God, of course.
>> Okay, so he says my my essence is
embodied in Thank you. I'm glad you
admit that.
>> And not necessarily doesn't necessarily
mean you
>> Okay, notice he said "does not
necessarily mean." So, that means it can
mean that, but you don't want it to mean
that because unless you're going to say
it never means that, then I'm going to
call you a liar. I want you to admit it
can mean that, right?
Well, I didn't say never, but I was
going to
>> See, listen, you'll see See what you're
doing again? Notice the tap dance. You
admit that it doesn't necessarily mean
that, but it can mean that. Since it can
mean that, why are you not bringing up
something irrelevant? Because the text
is clear. It's not "My name is close to
him." It has to mean "My name is in him"
because he explains the reason why he
forgives sins is "My name is in him."
So, let's stop trying to appeal to
Hebrew grammar as if this is going to
help your case. Well, you asked me to
observe the grammar. Yes. So, And can it
grammatically Let's make it clear,
Yossi. Can it grammatically mean "My
name is in him"? Yes or no?
I mean, not necessarily because if you
were going to say "My name is in him,"
you could say Okay. What you I want you
to do right now. Give me every time that
construction is used throughout the
Tanakh, and show me places where it
doesn't mean "in him."
Can you do that? Show me that
construction
>> doesn't Where it doesn't or does? Where
it doesn't mean "in him."
Okay. And for your argument to mean
every single time I want to see this
construction used, every single time, to
show me where it doesn't mean "in him."
Because if you can show me it does mean
"in him," that means you brought up
another irrelevant point, a red herring.
So, let's deal with the passage as it is
because what translation did you just
read?
It was a It was the Chabad
>> Okay, so let's stick with the point.
This angel embodies God's name, which
means he can forgive sins. So, look, can
you go to Zechariah 3 now? Can you go to
Well, I'm going to show you that he
forgives sins that you have problems
with this angel cuz he's a nightmare for
you and your rabbis. Go to Zechariah 3
and read verses 3 and 4.
Now, Joshua was wearing filthy garments
and standing before the angel, and he
and in parentheses, the angel raised his
voice and said to those standing before
him saying, "Take the filthy garments
off him." And he said to him, "See, I
have removed your iniquity from you, and
I have clad them I have clad you with
clean garments." Wow. The angel says,
"Remove his filthy garments." And then
the angel says to
Joshua, "I removed your what from you?"
Read verse 4 again. What did he remove?
>> Your iniquity. Oh, okay. So, the And
this is a heavenly vision that Zechariah
is seeing. So, the angel in heaven
removes the sins of Joshua, forgives him
of his sins, and clothes him with pure
garments. And he still want to convince
me the angel is not God because he does
what only God does, and he's doing it in
heaven. Convince me that he's not God.
This is in heaven? Yes, because it's not
on Earth. It's not on Earth, dude,
because if you read verses 1 and 2, he's
having a vision where he sees the angel
of the Lord, Satan Satan, and Joshua.
So, please, I hope we don't have to play
that game. This is a heavenly vision.
Even if it's not a heavenly vision,
let's put that aside. The angel is the
one commanding other angels and saying,
"I removed your sin. I removed your
sin," which is exactly what God said in
Exodus 23 the angel can and cannot do,
meaning he can forgive your sins or he
won't, not cannot do, meaning he doesn't
have the ability. Meaning either he will
forgive you or choose to condemn you.
So, don't get him angry because my name
is in him. So, again, I'm going to ask
you this question so we can make it very
simple and beautiful from your Tanakh.
Is there someone other than God who
forgives and removes sins?
No. Okay, say it again. Well, well,
well, then say it again.
There's nobody but God. Okay.
Explain to me Exodus Now, Exodus 23:21
and Zechariah 3:4 where the angel does
actually forgive sins and God says he
can. You just said only God can do that.
Now, please convince me that your
Judaism has not distorted the Tanakh to
deny that this angel is divine and he's
distinct from God, but one with him.
Is that essentially we can see
throughout the entirety of the Tanakh
that God uses angels, okay, as a you
know, by you know, as a means of a you
know, doing his you know, as a means of
a you know, medium essentially to
interact with you know, the interact
with his you know, people, interacting
with the sons of Adam on Earth. Now, we
know this cuz we can see, you know, for
example, the angel of the Lord wrestle
you know, wrestled Jacob. There was an
angel in the burning bush.
>> You're begging questions. You're going
too fast. No, Genesis 32 does not prove
your case because it's one specific
angel
who is called God because he is God.
You're assuming this is referring to
angels in general. I know what you're
referring to. Genesis 32 24 to 30
cross-referenced with Hosea 12:2-5. I
guarantee you'll see none of them
support you, they support me. And I'll
get to them. So, don't keep bringing
passages going to backfire against you.
Let's just stick with Genesis 31. Wait,
hold on. Just stick with Genesis 31.
Read for me 31:13.
Genesis 31:13.
Read it for me what the angel says cuz
we know it's the angel in verse 11,
right? So, you know, I don't need to
prove that to you. What did he say to
Jacob when Laban is persecuting, "I've
seen your affliction because I'm what?"
Genesis 31:13.
It says, "I I am the God of Bethel where
you anointed a monument, where you
pronounced me
where you pronounced to me a vow. Now
arise, go forth from this land and
return to the land of your birth." Okay
now, who said in verse 13, "I am the God
of Bethel"? Who's that speaking?
It says in verse 11,
which means "And an angel of God said to
me in a dream, Jacob." And I said, "Who
I am." Slowly repeat the phrase malakhu
slowly.
malakhu
Elohim
malakhu Elohim, right? You said kim
because you don't pronounce Elohim. All
right, okay, that's fine. All right, now
go to Genesis 35:1.
Because I want you to explain cuz you
say Elohim, so you won't say Elohim. But
I hope you don't mind me saying Elohim.
I don't follow that tradition, but you
do. Anyway, in Genesis 35:1
Genesis 35:1.
Yeah. Read it slowly for me because God
is telling Jacob to go to Bethel again.
Beth El Beth El the same place where the
angel said, "I am the God of the house
of God where you anointed a pillar and
made a vow to me." Now, in Genesis 35:1,
read it slowly for me.
And God said to Jacob, "Arise and go to
Bethel and abide there and make there an
altar to to the God who appeared to you
>> To who? when you fled from your brother
Esau."
>> Slowly. God said to him "Go to Bethel
and make an altar to who?"
To the God who appeared to you. Okay, so
I'm going to ask you a question and I'm
going to let you look at the Hebrew
grammar to confirm my point. Why is God
saying to Jacob, "When you go to Bethel
anoint
build an altar to the God who appeared
to you"? Why doesn't he simply say,
"Hey, when you go to Bethel, build an
altar to me who appeared to you"? Why is
he speaking of God in the third person
and
can you confirm the Hebrew's different?
It's Elohim Elohim said to him, you want
to say Elohim, "Build an altar to El
El."
The Hebrew words are different, right?
Mhm. Well Well, before you say well, no,
don't give me an example because in
verse seven, now read for me verse
seven. So, then you can give me your
response. But first now read verse seven
so I can sum it up and I'll let you give
your explanation. Verse seven reads
>> an altar
He built there an altar and he called
the place El Bethel for there for there
God had been revealed to him when he
fled from before his brother Esau. Now,
confirm to everyone here
the verb revealed to him
it's plural, isn't it? Mhm. Yes.
So, wait. Say it again. The one that
says God revealed to him, it's plural,
right?
Mhm. Literally it's Elohim when they
revealed themselves to him, literally,
right?
Mhm, yes. It's good. So, so far as the
people don't think I'm making it up.
Now, do you want more proof that the
angel himself is God which accounts for
why it says God they revealed themselves
to Jacob because you have Elohim
speaking of El the El who appeared to
Jacob at Bethel and that El is the angel
of God. So, you have God and the angel
together being called Elohim, which is
why it's plural. Elohim they revealed
themselves to him.